hello John Perry here welcome to the
third episode in this mini series on the
Ark Encounter last time we took a look
at Archaeopteryx a fascinating genus of
bird-like reptiles or reptile like birds
depending on how you look at them that
were extremely important in the history
of science because of their
extraordinary preservation the obvious
link they represented between birds and
dinosaurs and for their crystal-clear
confirmation that bird wings are in fact
modified arms and claws today we will
continue to explore these wonderful
fossils by looking at what Ken Ham has
written about them and posted at the Ark
Encounter here I will act as Ken Ham
science teacher I have a copy of what he
has written and I will grade it as if it
were a homework assignment for science
class will he get a b-minus a C+ will
Ken Ham get a solid a continue watching
to find out
[Music]
[Music]
all right here we go this is our third
episode on the Ark Encounter our second
episode about Archaeopteryx and for
those of you that have been following
along so far and if you haven't been I
highly recommend you watch at least the
last one you now know a lot about this
fossil genus known as Archaeopteryx and
with this knowledge when we look at what
Ken Ham has written about Archaeopteryx
it will become very clear to you that
Ken Ham has carefully worded each one of
his sentences to really there's no way
to get around it he is deliberately
misleading his own audience and for
those of you that have been you know
longtime fans and supporters of ken
ham's work maybe even given money to his
ministry this is going to be a very
disturbing revelation I want to point
out here that in this video series I am
NOT critiquing Christianity in general I
am NOT critiquing the life and Ministry
of Jesus Christ here we are just
critiquing the ministry and the tactics
of Ken Ham as mentioned earlier I am not
religious I was raised Mormon but I it's
probably been 10 years ago that I left
the faith of my childhood but there is a
website called BioLogos that you can go
to and it's a group of evangelical
Christians that have found ways to
accept the science of evolution while
also maintaining their Christian faith
and if you go on that website you can
read about how those people are doing it
and you might have some ideas for you to
adopt into your own kind of worldview as
well so I highly recommend that if you
happen to be a Christian and you're
finding some of the stuff you're
learning here to be you know troubling
I'd like to start out by just looking at
the you know artistic rendition of
Archaeopteryx at the Ark Encounter as
mentioned before the artists that were
involved in the production of the Ark
Encounter really did a great job on
almost all of the displays when I first
saw Archaeopteryx I thought he was a
little bit goofy looking he got as this
you know big bird look to him but the
more that I look at these photos it's
it's kind of growing on me
I like it they've chosen to give
Archaeopteryx lips which cover up his
teeth and that actually might have been
how Archaeopteryx was in life we don't
know for sure
there's never been a really good study
on lips of Archaeopteryx there has been
a study on lips in tyrannosaurids it's
fairly recent and there's only been one
of them that I know of and they
determined that t-rex and his kin did
not have lips that they probably sealed
their mouths shut in a similar way to
crocodiles but that's just one study and
that's only on tyrannosaurids so for
Archaeopteryx and other animals maybe
they did have lips
you know lizard lips the feathering on
the hands is probably a little bit off I
happen to have a surprisingly in-depth
knowledge on the feathering of
Archaeopteryx hands because a few years
back Howard Hughes Medical Institute
hired me to do a model of an
Archaeopteryx wing for them and so I
read through all the literature and we
think that the middle finger was
actually more covered up with feathers
then they have in their model at the Ark
Encounter but you know it's that's a
really common thing in museums to have
that a little bit wrong the tail however
was at least in these photographs seems
to be dramatically wrong and I can't
tell if that's just because of the weird
angle that I took this picture
I don't remember paying attention to
this when I was actually at the Ark
Encounter again remember Archaeopteryx
had a long reptile like tail with
feather sticking out of the side of each
tail bone whereas modern birds have
what's called a PI go style
it's a fused bone it's several vertebrae
fused together to create a little nub
and feathers stick out from that and it
looks like the way that they built those
Archaeopteryx is they built them with a
PI go style instead of a reptilian tail
it looks like that from this photo I
don't know if that's actually true but
if that is true then they did it wrong
as far as coloration goes we actually
there's a paper out right now that says
that Archaeopteryx was probably
completely black and the way that people
figure this out is that they they zoomed
in on a feather and they found these
little micro structures that look
similar to pigments that we find in
modern birds and those pigments resemble
black pigments in modern Birds
and so the people that did this research
have concluded that Archaeopteryx was
black or at least part of one of his
feathers that they looked at was black
now there is you know if you if you if
you talk to paleontologists such as Phil
Manning for example who also study
coloration in ancient
they'll say that this is actually a
pretty sketchy conclusion those
structures that have been interpreted as
pigment structures those actually might
be fossilized bacteria and so I would
say that the color of Archaeopteryx is
still still pretty much up in the air a
green Archaeopteryx is yeah that's I
like it they made him kind of cute and
approachable I'm fine with that but now
we get to the content written by Ken Ham
here is a photograph of the display on
Archaeopteryx and here I've I've taken
the liberty of writing it out in you
know middle school homework assignment
style and I'm going to grade this as if
I work in hams middle school science
teacher so if you look at what he's
written he makes 10 statements that you
could consider to be scientific
statements 10 truth claims what I'm
going to do is I'm going to look at each
one of these claims independently and if
the claim is both accurate and not
misleading I'm going to give them a plus
one if it is either false or misleading
and going to give it a minus one and
before I do this I should probably point
out that when somebody says something
that is actually completely false it's
possible that they're lying to you and
that's why they're saying things that
are false it's also possible that
they're just confused they don't know
what the truth is I tend to give people
the benefit of a doubt and say you know
the statements that can have mixedness
that are just absolutely false I'm going
to assume that it's because he's
confused but there are some things he's
written here that are so carefully
worded that they're they're actually not
technically false but they are extremely
misleading and to give you an example of
someone doing this that's not you know
Ken Ham related let's suppose that
there's a guy Jim who is married but
he's developed a little crush for
Elizabeth at his office and his wife
maybe has noticed this and she's getting
a little bit concerned and one day he
stays at the office late him and
Elizabeth stay late and they hang out
and maybe have some drinks and do a
little bit of flirting when he gets home
his wife confronts him did you go out
with Elizabeth tonight and he says no I
didn't go out I got held up at the
office
technically what he's saying is true
right he actually did get held up at the
office
he's just withholding all of the
information that's important he did get
held up at the office but he got held up
by his attraction to his coworker
you were going to see crystal clear that
Ken Ham is using very carefully worded
sentences so that he can technically not
lie but completely mislead his readers
this will be very very clear to you when
you see what he's written he starts by
saying this long branded as a poster
child of evolution Archaeopteryx poses
no difficulty for biblical creationists
so there's kind of two statements here
first is absolutely correct I give Ken
Ham a plus one for this first statement
Archaeopteryx has been long branded the
poster child of evolution and the reason
for that is that Archaeopteryx was
discovered right after Darwin published
the theory of evolution in his book on
the origin of species so yeah that first
statement is absolutely true
the second statement if Ken Ham is
talking about biblical creationism in
general his second statements actually
not true many different creationist
groups have has struggled for a long
time with Archaeopteryx it's been kind
of a thorn in their side right but I
have noticed that Ken Ham when whenever
he talks about biblical creationists
he's actually not talking about biblical
creationists in general he is talking
about Hammond ISM Hammond ISM is the
special version of Christianity invented
by Ken Ham he didn't invent every single
doctrine in it you know he's he's taken
a lot from other people but he's the one
that kind of organized this overarching
version of Christianity where there's
t-rex on the ark and there's hyper
evolution after the flood and I kind of
see this statement as a doctrinal
statement he's saying that within
Hammond ism he declares he the creator
of Hammond ISM is declaring that
Archaeopteryx poses no difficulty and
whatever it's it's his religion that
he's invented if he wants to say that as
one of his doctrines I mean I'm not
going to criticize that I'm gonna say
that this is just kind of scientifically
irrelevant we'll just ignore this second
statement so you got the first statement
right second statement is scientifically
irrelevant
moving on even many evolutionary
scientists
reject the idea that Archaeopteryx was a
direct ancestor of modern Birds a fact
that often remains unrecognized on a
popular level this statement is
technically true but extremely
misleading this is a very good example
of no honey I got held up at the office
the bit of information that Ken Ham is
very carefully excluded from this
sentence is the fact that every time we
find an animal in the fossil record that
is clearly related to animals that exist
today we never assume that they
literally are the direct ancestors of
the modern form and to help you
understand why this is it's helpful to
think of an evolutionary tree that you
might be more familiar with your very
own family tree let's suppose for a
moment that you have never met any of
your relatives on your father's side but
somehow one of your cousins
learned about your existence sent you a
letter and said hey there's gonna be a
huge family reunion all of our extended
family is gonna be there come meet us
all we'd love to meet you so you go to
the party and when you first get there
you see this guy who looks kind of like
you and he's old enough to be your
grandfather
now you could assume that he is your
grandfather maybe he is in fact but that
would not be a safe assumption because
your grandfather might have brothers and
your grandfather might have cousins and
so even though he is the right age and
even though visual cues are telling you
yes this probably is my grandfather
you cannot safely assume that this has
in fact the case when we look at
organisms in the fossil record unless
there's been DNA that's been preserved
all we have are visual cues that's the
only thing we have to go by and because
of that we can never assume with 100%
certainty that the organism we're
looking at is the direct ancestor of a
modern organism because of this every
time you look at an evolutionary tree in
a textbook that includes fossil
organisms here we have Tiktaalik which
is a transitional form between fish and
amphibians
notice that Tiktaalik actually has his
own branch in this evolutionary tree and
the scientists have drawn a branch that
goes down meets at a node and then goes
forward to in
and phibian like organism we do this
because we cannot say with certainty
from visual cues alone that Tiktaalik
actually gave rise to modern and fib
Ian's instead it might have been a close
relative of Tiktaalik that actually gave
rise to modern and fibia n--'s
scientists do not now suddenly doubt
that Archaeopteryx is a transitional
form Archaeopteryx is a transitional
form between reptiles and birds on the
second part of Ken Ham statement though
I'm going to give him a plus one it is
true that a lot of people don't
understand how it is that biologists
make evolutionary trees one of the
reasons for this is that so many people
in our community reject the theory of
evolution and get really angry when
teachers try to teach it in the
classroom I was just in South Carolina
last week I was going on tour to middle
schools at high schools teaching
evolution and the one of the middle
schools that I went to before I got
there the teacher was required to send a
letter home to the parents warning them
that they were going to be learning
about evolution the next day in school
and telling parents that it was okay to
have their kids skip class evolution
here in America is treated as if it were
some sort of a disease this is why
people do not understand how evolution
works it's not because teachers are bad
at teaching it's not because scientists
are trying to hide the truth from the
public it's because parents are freaking
out about evolution and they're freaking
out about it because people like Ken Ham
are telling people that evolution is
wrong and is a conspiracy and so on and
so forth
so yes Ken hammock I'm gonna give you
plus one for that people do not
understand how evolution works moving on
there is a deep lack of consensus among
evolutionists regarding the origin of
modern birds this statement is simply
false we have known since the time of
Darwin that birds evolved from reptiles
now during Darwin's time we didn't know
exactly which type of reptile birds
evolved from early on the evidence
suggested that birds may have evolved
from a group of reptiles called
orcas or morphs this is a group that
exists it's slightly before the
dinosaurs and actually the dinosaurs
evolved from them others believed that
the evidence was stronger that birds
evolved from dinosaurs
from theropod dinosaurs now if you look
at a modern textbook you know anything
written after the late 90s or so this
here is called the tangle bank it's a
really good one I highly recommend it
if you look at any recent textbook you
will find that this problem has been
solved here the author writes which
reptile ancestor did birds evolved from
for a century those questions remained
very much open but over the past 40
years thanks to new fossil discoveries
and careful comparisons of fossils and
living birds a consensus has emerged
Birds paleontologists now agree our
dinosaurs there are right now two guys
that are still looking into the older
arcus or morph origin of birds those
would be Alan fiducia and John Reuben
John Reuben happens to live a few blocks
away from me
it just add a random coincidence and I
actually had coffee with him this has
been a few years ago now and it was
really funny I was I was asking him
about this you know because creationists
quote him all the time and say look
scientists have no clue where birds came
from and John Reuben told me he said you
make videos lots of creationists watch
your videos make sure to tell them to
stop using my work to support their
garbage he was very upset but he said
yes
the consensus is that Birds definitely
evolved from dinosaurs that is the
consensus but he feels like it's his
responsibility as a scientist to
double-check that consensus to
triple-check that consensus when Ken Ham
says that there is a deep lack of
consensus among evolutionists regarding
the origin of birds that is simply false
next he says that new fossil specimens
as well as the way in which some
researchers now define birds as avian
dinosaurs have sparked disagreement on
how to classify Archaeopteryx this again
is another perfect example of a
half-truth no honey I got held up at the
office the way that he has worded this
it makes it sound like scientists are
confused about what Archaeopteryx is
they have no clue how to classify and
they're all arguing with each other
about this what's actually happened is
that in the late 90s we
began finding a whole bunch of new
feathered dinosaurs we found these
really cool critters like
Sinosauropteryx which this guy has a
special place in my heart I actually got
to draw a recreation of him for the
Howard Hughes Medical Institute and they
also let me use that in my stated
clearly animations really love this guy
a little little fuzzy dinosaur and we
found really cool things like a bead
acceptor --ax this thing existed long
before Archaeopteryx it had fuzz like
feathers all over its chest and had
these big long display feathers on its
tail it did not have flight feathers
this thing represents what animals may
have looked like before true flight had
evolved it might have had membranes
between its arms and its body it might
have been able to glide a little bit but
we're not totally sure on that and
because we've been finding so many
fossils that are closely related to
Archaeopteryx scientists have done a lot
of debate about which ones are most
closely related to other fossils so
there has been some debate and some
moving around within these new little
clades that we've been able to discover
but this has nothing to do with the
overall position of Archaeopteryx being
a transition between reptiles and birds
Archaeopteryx is definitely a transition
between reptiles and birds - one for
that misleading sentence
moving on regardless of how people
classify Archaeopteryx only animals
within a created kind are related here
Ken Ham is making a statement that has
simply not backed up by any factual
evidence young earth creationists have
invented a classification system for
animals called kinds and they claim that
one kind could not evolve into another
kind this claim has nothing to back it
up creationist and intelligent design
advocates might be he once wrote a book
called the edge of evolution where he
tried to explore this idea that things
can't evolve a little bit but there's a
wall that they run into well he hasn't
been able to find what that wall is and
no one has been able to find what that
wall is and in fact creatures like
Archaeopteryx show us that there is no
wall - one for that then he goes on to
say kinds never change into other kinds
again my
is one for that continuing on
Archaeopteryx was neither a missing link
nor a hodgepodge of different animal
traits now I kind of agree with them I
wouldn't use the term missing link to
describe Archaeopteryx I don't like that
word link because it sort of implies
direct ancestry it implies that we know
there's a chain and that he was a
missing link in that chain and then we
found him I shouldn't say him when I'm
talking about Archaeopteryx
Archaeopteryx is an entire genus of
animals not just one male individual but
you get what I'm saying here so the term
that I use instead of missing link is I
use the term transitional fossil but
Archaeopteryx is definitely a
transitional fossil and missing link is
sort of synonymous with that word so I'm
gonna have to give him minus one on this
first statement his second statement
where he says that Archaeopteryx is not
a hodgepodge of different animal traits
I can get behind that he's not a
hodgepodge of just like random animals
he's a mixture of reptiles and birds
more specifically dinosaurs and birds so
I'll give him a plus one for that and
finally a Ken Ham ends by saying rather
this creature was a complete fully
functioning and fascinating bird I'm
actually okay with this statement but I
recommend adding the word transitional
before bird so he's a fascinating
transitional bird and the reason that I
would add that is because it is actually
inaccurate to say that Archaeopteryx was
a complete bird he was actually missing
a lot of modern bird parts Archaeopteryx
did not have a beak
Archaeopteryx did not have the large
keel on his chest bone that modern birds
have Archaeopteryx did not have a PI go
style instead he had a long reptilian
tail so he wasn't really a complete bird
but he definitely was a fully
functioning animal of course he was if
he wasn't a fully functioning animal he
would not have survived to adulthood so
after adding transitional in there I
will give him a plus one for his final
statement there so if we add up ken
ham's score here let's see that's one
two three four statements that he
that were correct that's with me being
extra charitable on that last statement
here Ken Ham only got 40% that is an F
he got an F on his middle school science
project here but you know 40% that's
kind of a high F so I'm gonna go ahead
and be nice and I'm gonna give him an F
plus there you have it mr. Ken Ham this
is your final grade if you'd like I can
mail this to you you can hang it up on
your refrigerator so long for now stay
curious